if I mess up I immediately will have a
knee to the face so today I'm going to
shave my girlfriend's legs for the first
time please don't hurt me
I'm not gonna hurt you nothing I got you
you are shaking I know I'm really
nervous I think if anything Pilger
softer and maybe at first not get the
hair and then when he tries to get the
hair more he'll end up thinking me I
love him right now in this current state
with my hairy legs before he has done
anything to them you're gonna let me ask
you my expectations are that I'm going
to do a flawless job what happens if I
do a bad job what happens if you do a
bad job okay I don't want to think about
that I'm already shaking
[Music]
this parts actually kind of nice this
parts like getting a pedicure only Mike
can't yell mean things about me in
another language this is how you do it
[Laughter]
so you just want to keep it like give it
my razor oh my goodness this is how I do
it I don't know have you ever seen a
girl like even in a commercial shave her
legs no I've never seen okay cuz
nevermind don't do it going down with
you oh my god oh for God's sake okay
this is delightful but there's no way
you're shaving here you're definitely
just like getting shaving creams you saw
definitely too soft why would you go up
because it you're supposed to go against
the grain of the hair oh boy the shin is
a shame I didn't expect that
I'm very impressed I'm doing an
incredible job um what did I hear no but
it's interesting you're going so soft
that I almost wonder if I'm still gonna
have hair God be careful don't you just
go at it from a hack job angle that's
just like looks horrible all gone oh the
part with the with the SCAF the shin cuz
yeah I even all Nick myself there oh
it's just it's the part that was already
but you've already but look it's gonna
bleed just a little it's I'm sorry
you're beautiful you're beautiful you're
beautiful honey you know like there's
cream there
oh I can see your muscles
shake winching light from a couple
little strays he did a pretty good job
to me strays her a lot better than blood
I think Matt did really really well he
did nick me it's gonna hurt that was so
much more stressful than I thought it's
me and that was actually not as bad as I
thought it was going to be I mean you
did really good you got all the hair you
had a weird technique it's like a kitty
pawing at a leg for a first-timer he did
great
you have really nice legs which I
discovered today thank you just today I
still love me out okay good yes really
after you shaved my leg he's getting
overconfident the whistling starts I
feel like I'm out like an orb timey
barber shops barber shop the leg yeah